has come for us
my name is welcome to three free video
games
the show where I find the best
top-quality top-notch hmm let's just
play alright first game is called shark
lifting - it's a game about lifting
sharks oh they have a story that's
that's cool
after some years of struggle on the
probe wrestling circuit at the
big-breasted women what the [ __ ]
alright I'm already bored okay okay so
I'm controlling this plane and I need to
go to Puerto Rico Puerto Rico of course
I know where I know where Puerto Rico is
it's it's here of course of course I
know my geography of cos now we need to
lift a Caribbean reef shark ha easy for
these do you see these giant muscles yes
100% gaming quick click rapidly oh [ __ ]
I got a click to lift this shark but I'm
so distracted by the ladies I hope she's
watching this I haven't gotten something
since September come on man yeah yeah
that's right doggie I did that
oh [ __ ] it's already going isn't it
Hawaii all right all right
nice little detour we took there no
problems away it's over here hundred
percent what do we live now is sandbar
shark of course I write I write I write
it's like I lived in a dolphin [ __ ]
place this is how you do it
what if Jordan aah aah
I could feel the veins in my neck just
swell up those gaming mice it's an otter
oh [ __ ] here we go again Portugal
I actually know where that is I mean I
know where every city ever is there you
are Portugal Portugal are having some
trouble landing is that even a certain
just submit I'm still gonna lift yep
order this for you water Oh clicking is
intensified yes bet you wish you had
clicking skills like these mussels oh oh
[ __ ]
where we going Peru of course Peru Peru
is over here gross oh they're here
no problem Peru Peru is he having
trouble landing all right here we go
aah what the hell is that guy doing
dancing in the background oh oh that was
good very nice I feel like this the fin
is awkwardly covering my face that is
some nice [ __ ] underwear grandpa now
I'll show you who's boss
this is for my otter this is for my
honor
oh so good at lifting sharks CG Wow
never been to Fiji
oh [ __ ] me so many ladies I got to do it
for the ladies and grab of course
oh I should really get into
weightlifting hahaha
sharks Illustrated I'm famous I'm famous
British look at my signature yeah
alright well I'd do a little up Scrabble
and then a little D I'm scribble and
there it goes
alright I better sign summer here here
and I read a rebel a scribble screw it
that was beautiful all right I'm gonna
use two hands on this one
oh I can feel the muscles I feel like oh
that was a sweet burn man sweet burn
[ __ ] please give me a challenge the
amount of mental focus and not looking
at that weird as cameltoe it takes to
play this game bro so you don't even
know England Iran Iran maybe we will
visit pair two pair is that Brighton all
right breast
that was [ __ ] easy blue shark [ __ ]
look at the titties on that man I wish I
have tears like that when I'm older I
won't need much yeah if you know what I
mean please don't tell my say I'm
serious please it's not funny anymore
honey bro yeah baby
the [ __ ] are they doing in the
background all right I got Salman shark
I don't even know that was a thing said
of thing why would anyone take a Salman
oh that holy [ __ ] they looked terrified
oh my god oh damn it shut up Salman
shark where we go no stray there
oh my eyes closed these are really
getting [ __ ] out of hand man what am
I gonna leave the whale legs great white
shark here we go baby
ha ha oh ha ah too easy for these
muscles man whale shark [ __ ] please my
legs they're gonna crash ah my face his
face is like oh my god I broke my spine
Omega of course Megalodon oh this is a
final one all right look at me I love it
we're the cops doing here what the [ __ ]
chips kids stop me from lifting checks
and lifts check for life and we did it
all right all right all right that was a
great free game that could have been a
video by itself hey shut up please
alright friends hope you enjoyed this
video I hope you find some games that
you can check out yourself and I enjoyed
it with me and whatever you do now it's
a great time to leave a like it helps me
out a lot and supporting super channel
thank you both so much for watching
leave a comment about scissor e your sis
this is for my homeland this is for
Sweden nice it's perfect
this is for my homeland nice is for
Sweden but most importantly [ __ ]
[ __ ]